Whether they're meant to give us clues about
season 3 or to simply give us all a reason
to rewatch once we're done with our first
binge, here are some of the small details
you probably missed in The Umbrella Academy's
second season.
Spoiler warning for season two of The Umbrella
Academy.
At the end of season 2, the time-traveling
team successfully returns to 2019, only to
learn the Umbrella Academy seems to have been
replaced with the Sparrow Academy, apparently
led by a not-so-dead Ben.
"I-I'm just happy that we're home and together
again."
"Home?
This isn't your home."
These sparrows aren't the only birds flying
around the second season, though.
While you may not notice them before the Sparrow
Academy reveal, the official Umbrella Academy
Instagram page posted that there are exactly
43 sparrows in season 2 a significant number
since there were said to be exactly 43 superpowered
children born on October 1, 1989 in the show's
mythology.
Perhaps the easiest example to remember is
Harlan's sparrow toy, which we see him levitating
in the back seat of his mother's car towards
the end of the finale.
In "A Light Supper," eagle-eyed viewers can
spot a sparrow logo on the piece of paper
the Handler gives Five with the location of
the Commission's executive board a logo that
mysteriously disappears when Five looks at
it in the following episode.
Other examples of sparrow logos show up on
the dairy truck the Swedish assassins steal,
on the front door of the liquor store that
Klaus visits, on the room service menu Lila
looks at, and on yet another on a piece of
paper in Old Man Five's briefcase.
We haven't discovered them all yet, but the
prospect of finding them isn't a bad motivation
to rewatch season 2.
One of the bigger surprises in the season
2 finale is the crazy reveal that Lila is
one of the superpowered children born in 1989,
just like the seven members of the Umbrella
Academy.
Similar to Mimic of Marvel Comics' X-Men,
Lila can use other people's powers to her
own advantage.
And we see her gift on full display at the
Coopers' farm.
While at first it looks like the Academy has
slam-dunked the Commission in the season finale,
Lila is able to use their powers to even the
playing field.
"How are you doing this?"
"Anything you can do, I can do better."
But what you may not realize is this isn't
the first time in the series that she's used
her powers.
At the end of the episode "Valhalla," she
fights Five in a factory, and the melee [MEY-ley]
ends with Five's foot on her throat and with
the Handler revealing herself.
However, three times during their fight, Five
expects Lila to be one place, and she appears
in another.
Initially, we're supposed to assume she's
just unbelievably sneaky and fast.
But when you rewatch the scene with the knowledge
of Lila's superpower, it becomes clear she's
mirroring Five's teleportation.
The camera isn't on her when she uses it,
so we never see the ripple effect, thus keeping
her power a secret until the big showdown.
In "The Swedish Job," we get a quick look
at an unnamed character who's a pretty clear
reference to one of the most acclaimed graphic
novels of all time Watchmen.
Just after Luther starts off on a morning
jog outside his rooming house, an elderly
man carrying a placard reading "The END is
NIGH" appears and starts walking in the opposite
direction.
So what's the reference here?
Well, carrying a placard that warns of the
end of the world is just about all the vigilante
Rorschach seems
to do in Watchmen when he's out of costume.
And while the man in "The Swedish Job" doesn't
look at all like Rorschach, with his long
hair and full beard, he does have a passing
resemblance to Alan Moore, the author of Watchmen.
And it's a fitting reference for a couple
of reasons.
For one, just as the escalating tensions between
the United States and the Soviet Union provide
Ozymandias' motivations in Watchmen, it's
an apocalyptic conflict between these two
superpowers that Five is struggling to avoid
in The Umbrella Academy.
For another, just like Watchmen's Ozymandias,
Five employs some pretty reprehensible tactics
in saving the world, like traveling to 1982
and assassinating most of the Commission's
executive board with an ax, paving the way
for the Handler's takeover of the organization.
"She sent you, didn't she?"
"Does it really matter now?"
In the show's first season, we met Pogo, a
sophisticated chimpanzee butler with human
intelligence who is sadly killed by Vanya.
If you've ever wondered about the ape's origin
story, the second season has got your answers.
"Valhalla" opens with a flashback of the younger
Pogo as a part of an early project to see
how chimpanzees would be affected by space
flight and, by extension, what might be in
store for human pilots.
And two episodes later in "Öga for Öga,"
there's an easy-to-miss detail that could
point to Pogo being much more famous than
we realized.
When Five travels to 1982 Wisconsin to kill
the Commission's executive board, he stops
at a vending machine for a candy bar.
The one he winds up with is called a Fudge
Nutter, but right next to that bar is one
called Pogo Gogos.
And above the name on the wrapper, it reads,
"Take flight with..."
It's a small detail, but it says a lot.
For Pogo to have a candy bar named after him
suggests the intelligent chimp was much more
of a Space Age icon than we realized.
In the season premiere, while all the members
of the Umbrella Academy arrive in the same
place, they don't arrive in the same year.
"They're gone, like a fart in the wind.
Poof."
They fall from the portal into the same Dallas
alley, one at a time or two, in the case of
Klaus and the ghost of Ben between 1960 and
1963.
Interestingly, right across the street from
the alley is a movie theater, and in at least
three cases, the theater marquee is advertising
a very specific kind of movie.
When Klaus and the ghost of Ben appear in
1960, the marquee is advertising the 1959
film Curse of the Undead.
As Allison arrives in 1961, the theater has
apparently caught up with its releases, and
the marquee announces that year's The Curse
of the Werewolf.
The marquee during Luther's arrival in 1962
isn't really visible enough to read, but the
same film is playing during Diego's appearance
in 1963, when Vanya shows up a month after
Diego, and when Five arrives in November 1963
The Kiss of the Vampire.
Of course, in Five's case, the fighting between
the US and Soviet forces has blown most of
the letters off the marquee, and we doubt
the theater is still selling tickets at that
point.
It may be that the marquees are meant to reflect
the heroes' collective doubt expressed throughout
the season about whether or not they're heroes,
superpowered freaks, or as the marquees reflect
monsters.
In other words, it's not exactly the kind
of thing you want to see when you're suddenly
lost in the past and struggling with self-esteem
issues.
In the Umbrella Academy comics, the heroes'
hometown is left intentionally ambiguous.
In fact, it's referred to only as "The City."
But it looks like season 2 of the series has
revealed the location of the Academy's HQ,
at least as far as the TV adaptation is concerned.
In a flashback in "Valhalla," we learn that
as soon as he could, Luther gets on a Greyhound
bus in the hopes that he can find his father.
During the trip, there's an overlay revealing
the bus' progress on a map, showing that Luther
gets off somewhere in or around Indianapolis.
It's an interesting choice for a superhero
HQ.
Maybe the writers simply didn't want yet one
more superhero team hailing from the Big Apple.
Maybe it just seemed far enough away from
Dallas to be a long trip but not too long.
Or maybe Reginald Hargreeves is a big basketball
fan and just wanted to be near the Hoosiers.
When it comes to powers, Diego has a pretty
unique skill set.
The dude is a master of knives, able to make
blades spin through the air with the greatest
of ease and fly in any direction he chooses.
In the season finale, however, Diego uses
his powers in a way that we've never seen
before.
When the Commission's goons are firing on
him and Five, Diego buys Five the time he
needs to make it to the house by jumping out
from behind cover and stopping the hail of
bullets mid-air, a la Neo from The Matrix.
Speaking to Den of Geek, showrunner Steven
Blackman said that this is an extension of
the powers we've already seen before, explaining:
"If you think about Diego's power, he can,
with his mind, control the trajectory of objects.
Basically, he likes throwing, so he can throw
his knife, and he can make it go in weird,
odd curvatures and directions."
Blackman went on to say that the aftermath
of Ben's death hurt the chances that most
of the members of the Umbrella Academy would
reach their powers' full potential early on,
and that fans should expect for the heroes
to keep learning more about their abilities.
"Everybody wants to see powers all of a sudden."
Looking back on season 2, we've already seen
some of that.
For example, before season 2, Klaus has no
idea it's possible for a ghost to possess
him, and when spectral cowboys save him from
falling in the season finale, he seems as
surprised by it as anyone else.
Likewise, even before she lost her memory,
Vanya had no idea she could use her powers
to resuscitate someone — as she does with
Harlan after he drowns — or that doing so
would transfer her powers to him.
With every episode, the Umbrella Academy grows
stronger and stronger, and we can't wait to
see what weird directions their powers will
go.
One of the potential differences between the
Umbrella Academy show and the comics is that
in the source material, Diego has the ability
to hold his breath indefinitely.
So far, we haven't seen this power expressed
in the TV series... or have we?
A Reddit user going by the name high_arcanist
noticed something strange in a funny scene.
In "A Light Supper," the Academy members all
cram into an elevator on their way to meet
with their father.
Nobody is exactly looking forward to the meeting,
and at least one of the heroes is especially
anxious.
During the trip up, almost everybody on the
elevator reacts in surprise and disgust as
we soon learn Luther experiences some unpleasant
flatulence.
But there's one person who doesn't react as
negatively as the rest Diego.
While everyone else is scowling and covering
their mouths and noses, Diego is smiling,
seeming amused at the whole thing.
At no point does he seem to be suffering from
the stench as his brothers and sisters are.
This, high_arcanist believes, is because the
Diego of the show shares the breath-holding
ability of his comic book counterpart, and
so he's able to avoid most of the negative
aspects of the experience and enjoy the discomfort
of his adoptive siblings.
It certainly seems possible, though it could
also be that Diego just has a stronger stomach
for his brother's "nervousness."
In "The Seven Stages," Five enlists Luther's
help to do something that he warns is very
dangerous to contact an earlier version of
himself.
Doing this, Five warns, is incredibly risky
because of what he calls Paradox Psychosis,
which is a kind of psychosis a person may
undergo when encountering themselves in another
time.
There are seven stages of paradox psychosis,
and we watch both Five and Old Man Five go
through all those stages.
"You just itched your neck.
That's stage two of paradox psychosis."
"No I didn't.
I didn't itch my neck."
"Denial is stage one."
It's possible we see someone else go through
them earlier in the season.
Two of the seven stages are excessive gas
and homicidal rage, and in "A Light Supper,"
we see Luther exhibit both, on the elevator
and at dinner with their father.
"Look at what you did to me!
Look at it!"
And that kind of anger especially directed
at his dad is pretty unusual for our hulking
hero.
Blackman has said to expect things in season
2 to hint toward the future.
Could it be that another Luther maybe one
from a future season is lurking somewhere
nearby?
Of course, that would lead to the question
of why he isn't exhibiting the other symptoms.
Although it could be that wherever the future
Luther is hiding, perhaps he isn't as close
to the 1963 Luther as the Fives were to each
other or for quite as long.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.